you've been critical of Zion you've been
critical of Donovan Mitchell Joel and
beid only a negative person would look
at it as critical you should look at it
as information if I look at him and say
he shouldn't have took that shot he's
either going to say okay I'm going keep
taking it and make it this time or shut
you up or he's going to listen to what
I'm saying like you know what maybe I
should step in when I give you
information I'm giving it to you raw I'm
giving it to you like I would give it to
you if we was playing as a player you
know who you are shq shut your ass up
watch this you hit five in a row I can't
say nothing or you listen to what the
big man saying who's won for
Championship say you know what maybe
he's right a negative person would look
at it oh he's hating so like when I say
something that sounds like hate you
should slow it down and listen to what
I'm saying when I used to hear criticism
I used to say okay and I use it as
motivation and it helped me I love being
criticized cuz I have the ability enough
to slow down time and read what you said
and if there's some truth in okay a lot
of these players should take the
criticism and and turn into Mo
[Music]
motivation